spencer turple take the bump today
against this new york yankees team you
know what he's got he's got wicked stuff
fastball 94 95 with a two-seam variety
running to the end on the right-handers
away from the lefties went up one down
and rugnet odor because well he's the
hottest guy in this lineup he's in the
number two spot today another one too
and he caught him looking
i think that can be a huge pitch
for spencer terminal today against the
left-hander old door starts this ball
right at his hip and he gives up on it
that ball looks inside but look steve
payton on the inside corner two outside
brings up aaron judge
pounds one to right center mazara's
there
one two three first inning for spencer
turnbull davy garcia making his second
yankee start 5.17 era here's jamer
candelario
the pitch is swung on breaking ball
grounded to first
and ford will take it himself two way
two down that brings up the future hall
of famer miguel cabral
swing and a miss
so davey has a one two three first bases
loaded nobody out for the yanks
and there's one and there's two so a run
scores but that's exactly what the
tigers wanted torres crosses the plate
one nothing yankees no ribby for and
duhar
gardner at the plate and the o2
slow roller to short
so and in an inning in which he walked
three spencer turnbull battles through
it and allows just the one run
well the tigers got an opportunity right
here with the bases juiced
willie castro the one two
on the ground and
backhanded by o'doherty throws it wide
one run is home mazara trots home the
tigers have the lead
well i thought that ball was gonna be up
the middle but instead of taking his
time and trying to make an accurate
throw he throws it away so first and
third two ouches robbie grossman
odor from short right field gets
grossman and that will do it
dj le mayhew batting leading off in the
third inning
on a line oh speared by willy castro
from the seat of his pants he throws him
out
stop let's watch that again because that
never gets old great reflexes there
great jump on the ball lays out makes
the place he throws that ball over to
first base and he gets the mayhew the
2-2
swung out and missed second strike out
of the afternoon first spencer turnbull
both of them against roguenet odor two
away judge went two for five against the
tigers last night in the series opener
the 2-2
fly ball center field
crowd was wowed by it not a keel badou
one two three go to the yankees torres
the shortstop for the yankees leads off
fourth inning 2-1 tigers in the lead
that will be part and there's a
strikeout to start the inning for gleber
torres
and turnbull hopefully settling into a
groove now went away here's eric hoss
the 1-2 hammer to left center gardner
will give chase he'll watch it bounce
and up against the wall
haas has a double he'll dig for three
and he will get there with a head first
slide i mean he's really taking
advantage of every opportunity he's
getting every time he gets to the
battery box he looks comfortable here's
a good firm fastball right boom
absolutely hammers this ball to left
center another extra base hit for eric
haas
goodrum splashes one to deep center
field
gardner retreats he's got it shy of the
warning track that's a sacrifice fly for
nico goodroom give the tigers a two-run
lead on a job well done
he's in a one-two count here
and he's got the opportunity to to put
indoor away see ya does just that
change-up just ate him up inside what a
pitch
the one-two
strikes them out here in the fifth
inning
tamer candelario hit the ball hard as
last time up tigers one for five with
runners in scoring position now the
payoff to candelario down the right
field line and that is a fair ball into
the corner he will eat for two and he
gets a rbi double
two doubles for the tigers here in the
fifth they've opened up a three-run lead
aaron boone's gonna head out there and
hand this ball
to abraeu
well truncated action for abreu up and
down he's got a lot of frequent flyer
miles but three games for the yankees
five innings seven strikeouts galazzo
for two against the starter davy garcia
drives one to center field
[Music]
gardner camps under it that gets the job
done candelario tags the sacrifice fly
from miguel cabrera makes it 5-1 tigers
base is clear for jonathan scope the 1-1
hammered to deep left field
back goes and duhar that ball is gone
jonathan scope does it again
flex young man flex
right away jonathan scope recognize his
pitch
and boy did he unleash
gary sanchez is up for the yankees
another 2-2 he sits him down
[Applause]
damage
control
great finish by turnbull cisnero gets
the last out of the six
daniel norris second arm out of the
bullpen for aj hinch today
shift is on for frasier here's the 3-2
swung on and missed strikeout just as
good to away
3-2 to gardner
he struck him out
back-to-back punch-outs for daniel
norris daniel norris one of his best
outings may be the best outing of the
year for him one way now back to the top
of the order for the tigers here is
robbie grossman who has lined out
grounded out and popped up
and the o2 struck him out swinging on
another breaking ball
one up one down eighth inning three run
fifth now the payoff
and another base hit to left
strike three
mazara down looking
gary sanchez saw we had three outs there
huh
he was uh heading to the dugout
[Music]
well mixed up with the
ball three walk last night well maybe
he'll get out of here with only two outs
look at it what are you doing dude
hey wait a minute
joe jimenez taking over in the ninth may
not a man out ninth inning tigers
leading by five
swung out and missed
pretty darn good there striking out ford
for two away
now hoping to close it out against
miguel and duhar
popped it up
behind second base willy castro wants it
the tigers have beaten the yankees in
this series
the first time they've done it at home
against new york since august of 2014.